in 1999 Denise Richards co-starred
opposite Kirsty alley in drop dead
gorgeous the deadpan mockumentary was
about a small town beauty pageant and a
series of horrific murders committed in
pursuit of its Crown the film is now
considered a cult classic but was
underseen upon an initial release
Richards played Becky Lehmann the
presumed favorite in the team beauty
pageant contest unfortunately for
Richard 1999 was also the year she
co-starred in the World is Not Enough
starring Pierce Brosnan as James Bond
Richards played a nuclear physicist
Christmas Jones in the film but her role
was universally panned by critics
Yahoo's James Bond blog even had this to
say about Richard's part look of any
Pole or column from recent years on the
worst Bond girls ever and Dr Christmas
Jones comes up every time Dr Christmas
Jones came to represent all the cheese
and made bond fans sour and the Brosnan
films so in a way Denise Richards is
partially to thank for the grittier
Daniel Craig version of the character